vérification officer
lyon près le rôle inhabituel
sécurisation de l'habitacle en cours
derniers préparatifs avant mise à vue
enregistreurs de vols lancés
à quoi ça
à
[Applaudissements]
je réussis tout
m
cheng
vers l'infini
[Musique]
comment il s'appelle manie écoute on va
faire tout ce qu'il faut pour t'aider à
retourner auprès de mr
seul stop
où est ton père
fait de sortir je veux pas te flingue
chez moi alors qu'ils se barrent car
elle ta fille et l'a pas pas de voir
dans cet état qu'est ce que tu fous là
la présentation au magasin et souvient
18 ans papa
il va face en tirer comme ça
votre attention chers clients
exactement une heure une série
d'explosions va réduire cet endroit en
sentent à moins de voir aux infos qu'un
procureur porte plainte contre le membre
du congrès sanef le magasin est à moi ou
m'appartenait tous désormais s'il te
plaît ne meurt pas
tu te sauver ma vie yvon pays
on a beau me dont la cegos 1
je sais que tu m'écoutes espèces tour
carrée de fils de [ __ ]
pas
actuellement je l'avais prévu
je devais prendre tout ce qu'il a même
si c'est la dernière chance le père
[Musique]
ils vendent des munitions ici je sais
que tu peux avoir une réduc
cet enfant a une structure cérébrale
tout à fait unique
une nouvelle forme de génie
[Musique]
nous voulons tous savoir ce que pensent
ou ressentent les gens
cela signifie que nous pourrions accéder
aux pensées au souvenir d'un sujet mais
qu'est ce que ça nous apporte
vous voulez piraté le cerveau humain est
ce que tu as vu
[Musique]
j'ai vu quelque chose
vous êtes encore suspect dans une
affaire de meurtre
différents souvenirs se mélangent dans
ma tête et je ne veux pas les triais
qu'est ce que vous voulez savoir sur
votre fils
donc vous avez les souvenirs de turbines
dans votre tête
souvenirs auxquels j'ai accédé
tête est formé extrêmement
je sais plus aujourd'hui
notre avis
j'aimerais vraiment avoir un enfant dit
walton heath brahma
je ne sais pas si je peux me permettre
en ce moment il s'agit pas de savoir si
on peut se le permettre ou non l'enfant
est déjà là
mais papa tout va bien se passer
les soldes chez ma mère
[Musique]
je peux le voir
il va être très brune comme toi
[Musique]
les plus en plus typé en direct
je crois parce ça m'a fait du bien
[Musique]
j'ignore ce que ma fille a pu te dire
sur moi
[Musique]
et ouais t'as pensé à moi tout le temps
j'ai pensé à toi
[Musique]
japon 1971 les à une entreprise qui
rejettent des produits toxiques les gens
tombent malades il faudrait que le monde
antilles soit au courant les chais ce
qui se passe les chip à minamata allez
vous faire [ __ ] johnny depp dans la
peau d'une légende du photojournalisme
c'est à faire quand on est enfant est un
sujet au moins aussi brûlants que la
pollution elle même votre film canal+
première inédit en salles minamata mardi
à 21 heures seulement sur canal+
alors celle-ci
si la grande ourse et fessiers la grande
qui brille là bas c'est la terre
excellent en
interne et plus vivable comme elle
l'était et c'est pour ça que vous êtes
partis mais participent à ce que vous
voulez quelque chose lumière
on a de la chance d'avoir cet endroit
ouais là nous posera si ok tu bouges pas
dit
tu vois quelque chose
cadettes kanye west
tu ferme la porte derrière noir
papa
[Musique]
cette maison c'est pas la vôtre
et j'ai même fait un long voyage
maintenant je reste là vous pouvez
partir si vous voulez on peut sauver
alors
confort est impossible
donc tu veux savoir ce qu'il y à d'or
que dalle
et c'est le seul endroit qui reste
il des autres colonies a plus rien
plus tôt tu l'acceptera plus tôt tu
réaliseras
tout ce qu'il nous faut ici
moi
je veux que cette guerre se termine
des informations des services secrets
britanniques à propos d'un scientifique
intéresse le haut commandement américain
un expert en missiles je travaillais sur
une nouvelle arme mortelle fission
nucléaire
ordres du haut commandement de
réquisitionner votre équipe pour cette
mission il est prisonnier des nazis il
nous le faut
ces messieurs ont besoin que vous alliez
récupérer un petit colis pour eux en
pologne
on est là pour faire le job et c'est ce
qu'on va faire je vous suis
je vous offre une chance de survie
intervenir espoir de vivre en homme
libre
je sais que votre pays a besoin que
j'aille jusqu'au bout de mes recherches
tous les soldats allemands sont sur le
quai
des mots
[Applaudissements]
le point de rencontre est à 30 km en
territoire ennemi c'est l'arrière cour
dit leur fabienne est la clé qui peut
mettre un terme à la guerre c'est le
moment vous êtes prêt à 2
il est vraiment si dangereux que ça
[Musique]
regarde
c'est incroyable
plonge
bien par là et tout à trac mon épée
et sur cour et
alors comment tu fais ça rien de spécial
je galope c'est tout
notre palefrenier est un bon oeil
intégral
mais les gens l'adorent non mais quelle
frime on ne peut pas lui couper la tête
comme ça
enfin j'étais
confirmant une mission mais pas trop
facile il faut au moins qu'il y ait du
danger me kelidjian alors ça tu tombe
bien trash arrive à ckoi ivan ton de
sarah dorette a confié une tâche que nul
ne peut réussir
petit cheval regarde
c'est un monde où règne la magie et
l'illusion la route sera longue
le tsar m'envoie vous cherchez
attention
risquer de tomber
[Musique]
oh
je t'aurais bien rattrapé plus tôt mais
mais elle était un peu engourdie
et comme il fallait s'y attendre ce
benêt est tombé amoureux chinois
une princesse doit épouser un roi
d'impact premier
faire une raison
prépare toi on s'en va non il est encore
plus têtu qu'une mule
parce que seul un authentique nigaud
comme toi se préoccupent plus des autres
que de lui même ses abords
[Musique]
c'est magnifique
allez continuez à part
[Musique]
je vois là
d'ailleurs c'est vrai voilà
dis moi le vent situées où elle se
trouve cette bague par la baleine géante
elle a été avalée
mathé
[Musique]
attention il va
hébergeur saison
vous voyez c'était une fille très
géniale
c'est moi hier viennent là
ce que je vois zelimir pompe 6eme rei
c'est lé destin
tu sais pourquoi on dit un pompier est
pas une confièrent sirling non c'est
parce que les filles n'ont pas le droit
de devenir pompier
c'est contre le règlement
les filles peuvent pas être pompier mais
bien sûr
bonjour je veux dire bonjour il ya
quelqu'un
[Musique]
d'accord
tu es un des volontaires
est-ce qu'on se connaît
laisse moi te présenter ton équipe le
cerveau de la bande un grand spécialiste
de la chimie
d'accord d'accord tina ton chauffeur de
taxi le plus rapide de manhattan
p qui toi au moins je suis jo c'est ça
jo je suis pompier ce tuto le premier on
se calme joker bien méritée
pression de l'eau
ça ce spécial le pyromane de broadway à
incendier un nouveau théâtre de la ville
entière est en danger
tenez vous prêts
on me bats
j'ai pensé à ma fille tu doives à peu
près le même âge il voulait être pompier
aussi
alors pourquoi vous lui apprenez pas
comme à moi parce que c'est ma fille
je l'aimais je suis déjà un qui pourrait
à chaque seconde
spectacle connaît
peut-être que c'est un signe qu'il est
temps de poursuivre vos propres rêves
jamais abandonner les biens